um at the time i was uh surprised it
went viral
um i didn't think much would come of it
wasn't expecting anything to come of it
but obviously since then a year on and
um you know lots have been
a lot of people have spoken to me and
i've had lots of uh really really
positive uh feedback on it
and so i know i kind of understand that
it's almost like a a part of history now
so yeah i
i get it now but at the time i didn't
yeah i mean it is a part of history
because
amidst all the the protests and and the
anger and understandable anger
it is a a sign of unity well maybe not
on behalf of the fellow you are carrying
but
a sign of unity from you which i think i
mean
says more than a thousand words doesn't
it
well yeah i mean um you know if it had
been a black guy carrying a black guy or
a white guy carrying a white guy
he wouldn't have had the you know the
same uh
sentiment but the fact that it's a black
guy carrying a white guy
and then we're both there on on the day
for opposing reasons
i think that's what says it all and
that's why the picture is so powerful
um where are we 12 months on do you
think because i mean certainly
the the the fact that the killing of
george floyd caused
this global tidal wave
actually were you surprised at the time
of the impact it had here in the uk
and what sort of legacy as it left us
um i wasn't surprised um it's probably
one of the most harrowing things i've
ever seen
on on tv live i i i have it up there
with um
i don't know with grenfell with the 911
of things i've actually seen on tv that
uh that you know that i wouldn't want to
ever see again
so um it didn't surprise me in terms of
uh
what the impact it would have had in in
our country over here i mean
listen there's lots of political
posturing and flag waving
and a nice sentiment but on the ground
what has really changed
you know are our children still being um
excluded at an alarming rate
um in state schools yes they are um are
we
is there a huge disparity when it comes
to the criminal justice system and black
people
yes there is you know are we being
sectioned
uh a more of a uh you know a higher rate
than our white counterparts when it
comes to mental health
yes we are so there isn't anything
that's had
happened tangible that i can point to
but the positive thing is that
the conversations are being had we are
talking about it
the uncomfortable conversations you know
the full provoking conversations
are being had and i guess black people
are no longer feel they have to dump
themselves down
in in their corporate spaces that's a
positive
i mean is is that a real thing because a
lot of
i mean i was saying to someone earlier
to david lammy actually earlier on one
of the big things for me is
as a as a white person
it's like i didn't i didn't know this
was happening i didn't know it was going
on
i didn't think i was blind to it but it
just wasn't happening within my
vision and and and how important is it
then that we are made aware
of what is happening in our society
well this is the thing i mean like i
mentioned it in my book
um a lot you know everyone versus racism
related to my children
and um i feel like uh we have to come
together as a society
it's totally understandable that if it's
not uh sort of happening to you then you
kind of don't
really i don't know you don't you don't
sort of see
uh you don't understand it but for me
now as a society now that we all know
it's happening now that we we see what's
going on
we have to come together as a collective
you you know you know
unify unified to uh to make this change
happen
because you know racism isn't a black
person's problem
ultimately it's not so then why are we
left to try and figure out for ourselves
that's not right you know and if you're
not part of the solution you are part of
the problem
and i've always thought that yeah i mean
it's part of the problem here with what
why
why we maybe haven't seen anything
happen in the last 12 months
particularly is that a lot of this is
is systemic and it's it's about you know
the
the the sort of socio-economic struggle
to put it in those terms i mean these
are these are fundamental problems that
are going to take a long time to sort
out aren't they
yes they are you know when i was growing
up everything was over it was in your
face
um now it's very very covert it's very
very it's systemic
it's the unconscious bias that's what we
have to deal with now and that is going
to take a
long time you know it's woven in the
fabric of our society
and it's going to take some time uh to
to change things
but you know we have to start now we
have to start now so that you know
my great grandchildren and my
grandchildren you know have that uh that
level playing field that i'm always
talking about
it you talk about things not being uh
overt and it's a lot different from what
it was 30 40 years ago
the problem is when voices like yours
come forward it does
trigger some of those more over racism i
mean we have seen a bit of an increase
in that haven't we i mean
online and what have you
well yeah i mean obviously when i say
over um
i mean more like on tv and individuals
you know using the p word or the n-word
you know
i used to hear that almost every every
day but um
yeah true you have trolls i i'm really
sorry to jump in we are
just about to fall off air but it's
really good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed
no worries bye